and you meddled in the Olympics quit
pretty soon pretty young in your boxing
career from the time you started
training correct how long was it in
until you're fighting the Olympics I
made the lippisch team in a year and a
half I started boxing I started boxing
at 21 you know I'm [ __ ] crazy that is
know so a year and a half of boxing you
make the Olympic team and you win a
bronze medal mm-hmm that's that's insane
you know that even had my name written
on the list of the one that's gonna be
on the team you know they always say I
was I just came on know where or how I
came out of nowhere
yeah you know I remember been in a UH in
a tournament and I'm had this elder man
you know he's seen these kids they're
like year at the year at the year and
I'm he I remember him saying I said who
are you
I said I'm Deontay Wilder and he looked
at his the guy next to him you know were
you from I said I'm from Alabama Alabama
he laughed at media because they never
seen no one from Alabama you know you
know we was based on football and
basketball and stuff like that I didn't
even I was surprised it was a gym in our
number when I did start I was like wow I
can't believe like I'm in a boxing gym I
never thought one would be here we
didn't do that you know we just heard
about it but I started because of my
daughter that was born with spina bifida
so you know I couldn't play football or
basketball anymore because you had to go
to school for that I needed money right
now you know so I was looking at a way
of making money like right now and you
know I had a friend in college we was
always talking about what we want to try
to do it what are the things we're
trying to do to get to that point
because you know talk is cheap
we don't always saying what we want but
if you're not applying any type of
action towards what you with your words
you just it just is just talk you know
he said he thought I said box he thought
I should start boxing you know I thought
it was a great ideas where to he thought
it he thought I should start but only
for the simple fact that I handle myself
well streetwise you know nobody ever
seen me just lose or get beat up
streetwise I was this quiet guy I tell
people I never look for trouble but
trouble always found me
reason and and when I did release the
anger when I released like it was it was
even back then was dramatic
kid you not even back then I believe you
know and I couldn't never calm down
don't worry at that point I was like the
Hulk
I couldn't calm down it took me a lot to
come down even if I would see blood I
still went calm down and it used to be
scary for me because I you know even
back then I had power but I was just I
had a lot of aggression I had a lot of
anger for some reason I never know why
you know and and we thought it was a
great idea I like you know what i'ma do
it you know I can't lose what can I lose
you know and just went to the met up
with the guy went to the gym you know up
in Tuscaloosa Alabama and I walked in
there I kid you not I feel like I heard
the bells I mean the heard the sounds
the heavenly said oh I swear I hit when
I walked up in there it was just the the
speed bag and a heavy bad being hitting
the conversations and then the guys
sparring and my eyes is anyone I never
been in so a place like this before ever
you know just it's like new to me and I
like I felt like this was it this is my
last opportunity to be someone to be a
professional athlete and be able to make
money for my daughter I didn't know I
came in as a journeyman jennasmith
that's what I wanted to be I didn't
wanna you know I didn't know nothin
about amateur and I knew about Ally and
the what you know what he did his
journey is amateur but I knew that I
didn't know the term of an amateur like
what what is it you know sir
so walking into the gym my whole
mentality was to make money for my
daughter
I don't like y'all let me learn just the
fundamentals and she stick me out of
there but then we also we had this
conversation in the gym about the
Olympic Trials and the Olympics
so I remember a briefly like we started
talking about me and my trainer now we
started talking about it and then it
just became a whole big gym discussion
everybody stopped doing what they was
doing just to get in on this
conversation we didn't know how to get
there well we knew that if we kept
winning that will but we'll really get
to that point so I just kept knocking
guys out I just killed
kept winning and then that's how I got
on the Olympics team and then I told my
daughter when I you know I made the
Olympics team my medal and did all that
and then I turned pro shortly out there
and I remember telling my daughter when
she was 1 years or said that is gonna be
a world champion he's gonna be able to
support you beyond your belief you know
for me it meant a lot for me to say that
tour because I come from a place for
unfulfilled premises you know you ever
had someone promise you something you
wait for years and years it don't happen
you know you still holding on to that
promise that they told you especially
being a child you know you still like
all right you know until it's just don't
happen no more or you see that certain
thing that was positive been given it's
no more there it's gone
you know and that really hurted me you
know what I'm just coming up that's why
I'm a man of my word now you know if I
tell someone something you can take it
to the bank you know it's gonna happen
you know it's just you know god it's on
time God so it don't come we want it but
it's always on time when he's involved
and when I'm involved when I say
something I try to make it it's gonna
you know I'm a man of my word no matter
what I say